what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
it's been a while since i've done one of
these videos but since marvel studios
has announced
so many new projects and since marvel
studios has admitted that there are a
lot of projects that they haven't
announced yet
i figured it was time to do another
video on all of the projects that marvel
studios has coming up
what exactly is the status of each film
when their release date is or when we
can expect their release date to be
and of course talk about those secret
mcu projects that they have not yet
announced
so far they've announced about 25
different projects and if you include
the ones that they haven't announced yet
we have well over 30
mcu projects that are going to be coming
up over the next few years
and i'm going to talk about every single
one of them and list them in order
in this video quick reminder i'm giving
away a marvel legend
stormbreaker all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel
subscribe to cosmic culture and the rest
of the giveaway details are in the
description down below
so i think that most people probably
know most of the phase 4 announcements
and when they're going to come out so
i'll go pretty quickly over that
the next marvel project coming up is
loki it is in post-production and it is
scheduled for release on june 9th
of 2021 not too much longer about a
month away
then a month after loki we have black
widow coming out on july 9.
now of course black widow has been done
for a pretty long time at this point and
they have officially announced that it
will be released
in theaters and on disney plus
simultaneously so you can choose one or
the other or
both then after black widow we have
marvel's what if coming out in the
summer time of this year now we have not
been given
an official release date for this yet
but considering the fact that black
widow comes out in july and the next
project comes out in september we could
probably assume that what if is going to
be in
august otherwise that would mean we are
getting two different marvel projects in
one month
and that project in september is shangqi
and the legend of the ten rings it is
currently in post-production
filming has been completed and its
scheduled release date is september 3rd
of this year then we have marvel's
eternals coming out november 5th
this week we got our first look at the
eternals it was sort of a teaser of a
teaser and just judging by that it looks
pretty great already
and of course the eternals has been
completed for some time now
then we have the miss marvel series and
the hawkeye series now these don't have
official release dates yet but we do
know that the miss marvel series is
going to be coming before the hawkeye
series both
are going to be coming out in late 2021.
miss marvel will probably come out in
november
right after the eternals and then
hawkeye is going to come out in december
most likely
probably before spider-man no way home
spider-man no way home of course is the
next one and it is coming out on
december 17th
of 2021 it's going to be the final mcu
project of 2021 and even though 2021's
lineup is
fantastic and i'm super excited for
pretty much every project they have
coming out and there are some big movies
like the eternals coming out
i do think that if all of the reports
and rumors for spider-man no way home
are true
this is going to be the biggest movie of
the year and probably one of the biggest
movies of all time
now 2021 is packed full of marvel
projects but 2022 is definitely going to
give it a run for its money
kicking off 2022 of the marvel cinematic
universe is doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness releasing on march
25th now it would make sense that doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
would be the first mcu project
of the year following spider-man no way
home because we know that they're going
to connect we know that doctor strange
is going to be
in no way home and the events of no way
home will directly influence the events
of multiverse of madness
then following up multiverse of madness
is going to be thor
love and thunder it's going to be
releasing on may 6th of 2022
thor love and thunder right now is
currently filming and a lot of people
are going to be in this movie in fact
just a couple of days ago sasha baron
cohen was spotted having lunch with some
of the cast members
matt damon's going to be in it melissa
mccarthy russell crowe is going to be
playing zeus
and of course christian bell as gore the
god butcher and with taikuatiti coming
back to direct it again i'm pretty sure
it's going to be pretty bonkers
then following up thor love and thunder
is black panther 2
wakanda forever coming out on july 8th
of 2022
now right now there is a lot of mystery
surrounding wakanda forever
but the cast has assured us that ryan
coogler the director
has found a great way to rewrite the
story and also
honor chadwick boseman which is really
great now
following wakanda forever we have the
marvels aka captain marvel 2 coming out
on november 11th of 2022
the marvels that we know of so far are
of course going to be captain marvel
miss marvel and the third marvel is
believed to be monica
rambo who at one point in time in the
comics does become
captain marvel she recently got her
powers in one division and she is
confirmed to be in the marvels
now we also have she-hulk and moon
knight that are going to be released in
2022 as well
both of them are currently filming and
both do not yet have an official release
date but there is a
three-month gap between wakanda forever
and the marvel so we can assume that one
of these
is going to go in between most likely
she-hulk because that's what's rumored
to come out first
moon night could also be in one of those
three months or it could be in december
of 2022.
however we do have the guardians of the
galaxy
holiday special coming in late 2022 and
we can presume that's going to be
in december and this particular project
should be a lot of fun
then we have a few that are coming in
2023 that are in pre-production that
don't have official release dates yet
and those are
secret invasion iron heart and armor
wars
all of which are in pre-production right
now now those will most likely come
in the middle of 2023 because starting
2023 we have
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
coming out on february 17th of 2023
followed by the guardians of the galaxy
vol
3 coming out on may 5th in 2023 so one
of them will probably come out between
ant-man and guardians of the galaxy
one right after guardians of the galaxy
in the middle of the year and then
another at the end of the year
now during the trailer that marvel
studios gave us the other day that
announced release dates for plenty of
new shows
the last marvel project that they
mentioned was the fantastic four but
they did not give us a release date
however since they piled it in with the
other films being released in 2023 we
could assume that it's going to be late
2023 or
possibly very early in 2024. however
more than likely it is going to be late
2023 so we only have about a year and a
half left until the fantastic four
entered the mcu
then of course we have blade which was
announced at san diego comic con in 2019
it's currently in pre-production
although recently it was announced that
its release date will be pushed back so
we don't have a release date for it at
this point in time
we also have the i am groot series
coming which we don't have a release
date for either however both
blade and i am groot will probably be in
2024
and they will be joined by deadpool in
2024
as well as we are getting a deadpool 3
yes with ryan reynolds
yes it is going to be rated r it's in
development right now but we do not have
an official release date
and last but not least for what marvel
has officially announced we have the
wakanda series coming to disney plus
we don't have a release date for it yet
it seems very clear that marvel studios
is going to work on black panther 2
first and then the wakanda series will
probably take place after all of the
events of black panther 2.
now those are all of the projects that
have been officially announced by marvel
studios and if you're thinking that's a
lot of projects
yeah it is however marvel is actually
sitting on a lot of projects that are
currently in pre-development or
development that they haven't announced
yet
this was confirmed by malcolm spellman
the showrunner for the falcon and the
winter soldier when he recently said
that he was surprised by how few
projects marvel studios has actually
announced meaning that he's actually
seen the other projects and was
surprised that marvel studios has not
yet revealed them
this doesn't come as too big of a
surprise as marvel studios president
kevin foggy has already stated that
whatever they've announced they usually
have
six plus years already planned after
those shows
so right now marvel studios has pretty
much already planned all of their movies
and shows out to 2030
and based off of some reports we have a
good idea of what some of those could be
for starters it's been announced that
there are two new captain america
projects in the works
malcolm spellman is actually working on
one right now for sam's captain america
it's also been reported that steve
rogers is actually going to return in
some way shape or form and another
captain america movie based off of the
old steve could be in the works right
now as well
again neither of these are that
surprising considering the massive
success that the falcon and the winter
soldier had
and steve rogers as captain america has
always been really popular
another project that kevin feige has
actually stated that they will be
working on at some point in time if they
aren't already
is nova now they've already kind of set
him up in the mcu
thanos decimated zandar presumably
killing everybody on the planet
including all of the nova corps which
would mean that the nova fours
could go on to richard ryder now then we
have the group
the illuminati an illuminati project has
been reported by a few sources at this
point in time including the illuminati
and geekgossitymag.com
with reports that they could be
introduced in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness perhaps in a
post-credits scene if not not too long
after the movie
the midnight suns have also been
reported to come to the mcu relatively
soon and considering the fact that
marvel is releasing blade
moon knight a rated r deadpool they're
kind of going to introduce sort of a
monster verse inside of the mcu with
some darker characters that i think a
lot of people are really going to enjoy
then of course a thunderbolts and dark
avengers team
we've got reports that both of these
teams are coming to the mcu for some
time now but especially
after the falcon and the winter soldier
people have been wondering when
exactly are the thunderbolts going to be
set up or the dark avengers team
well according to grace randolph at
beyond the trailer they are going to be
two separate teams and marvel is
currently working on both of them
right now of course we have a mutants
project coming
kevin feige announced the mutants were
coming at 2019 san diego comic con
and not much has really been heard about
them since except for about a couple of
months ago it was reported that the
project is currently being worked on and
then we have the famous
wolverine anthology series that is
reportedly coming as well
this project will reportedly explore
wolverine from the very beginning in his
weapon x years
up until whatever they have planned for
him in the upcoming mcu
and of course last but not least you
know it's coming a new
avengers team now marvel is introducing
a lot of new teams like the thunderbolts
the fantastic four
the mutants but they're not going to
forget about the avengers
and it actually looks like sam is set up
quite nicely to be the leader of the new
avengers and of course we'll be getting
another avengers movie at some point
down the line
now these are only a handful of movies
that have been reported there are
definitely a
ton more projects that marvel studios
has yet to announce
since kevin feige said that they
essentially have the next eight years
planned that's over
50 marvel studios projects that we have
no idea what they are
so if you were excited about the mcu
before it's about to get a lot more
exciting within the next couple of years
but in the meantime let me know which
marvel project you are most excited
about
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest marvel news don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow
me on instagram and twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof